Bonjour à tous, aujourd’hui
on va parler d’une grave crise
qui secoue le petit monde
de la cosmologie.
Rassurez-vous, pas de drames
et encore moins de meurtres,
mais un désaccord profond
entre deux méthodes,
censées pourtant mesurer la même chose:
la constante de Hubble.
Cette constante, c’est un des paramètres
les plus importants de la cosmologie.
Et plus les méthodes de mesure progressent
et deviennent précises,
plus il semble qu’elles conduisent
à deux valeurs
différentes et foncièrement incompatibles.
Aujourd’hui, on va donc parler de cette crise
sobrement prénommée:
"la tension de Hubble".
[jingle]
La constante de Hubble, c’est une quantité
qui apparait quand on étudie
l’expansion de l’Univers.
Quand on regarde les galaxies dans le ciel,
presque toutes semblent s’éloigner de nous,
et ce d’autant plus qu’elles sont distantes.
Sur ce graphique par exemple,
vous voyez la vitesse
et la distance par rapport à nous
d’un grand nombre de galaxies.
Et manifestement, il y a une belle loi
de proportionnalité entre les deux.
On appelle cela la loi de Hubble-Lemaitre,
en hommage à Edwin Hubble
et Georges Lemaitre, qui avaient fait
cette observation
pour la première fois dans les années 1920.
Si on regarde dans le détail, en abscisses
on a donc la distance,
qui est exprimée ici en Mégaparsecs.
Oui c’est l’unité de distance préférée
des astronomes,
un parsec ça vaut un peu plus
de 3 années-lumière.
Donc un mégaparsec (Mpc) , c’est en gros
3 millions d’années-lumière.
Et en ordonnées, la vitesse est simplement
en km par seconde.
On voit que pour les galaxies, la vitesse
est proportionnelle à la distance,
et on peut alors estimer la constante
de proportionnalité: environ 70 km/s/Mpc.
Cette constante, on la note H0 (H zéro)
et on l’appelle la constante de Hubble.
Pour arriver à tracer ce genre de graphique
et mesurer la constante de Hubble,
évidemment il faut, en abscisses,
pouvoir mesurer les distances,
et en ordonnées les vitesses d’éloignement.
Pour les vitesses, cela se manifeste
dans la couleur des galaxies.
Par un effet qu’on peut comparer
à l’effet Doppler,
la lumière d’une galaxie qui s’éloigne
subit un décalage vers le rouge qui est lié
à sa vitesse d’éloignement.
Une galaxie nous apparait d’autant
plus rouge qu’elle s’éloigne vite.
Vous vous demandez peut-être comment
on se rend compte
que c’est bien dû à la vitesse d’éloignement.
On pourrait imaginer qu’une galaxie
soit simplement
naturellement plus rouge que la nôtre.
Pour bien faire le distinguo,
on se base
sur les raies d’absorption
et d’émission des atomes.
Comme ces raies correspondent à certaines
transitions
de niveau d’énergie dans les atomes,
on connait leur longue d’onde théorique,
et si on les observe avec un décalage
dans le spectre d’une galaxie,
cela permet d’estimer sa vitesse
d’éloignement.
Par exemple on a ici une reconstruction
comparée du spectre du soleil,
ainsi que d’un groupe de galaxies située
à environ 1 milliard d’années-lumière.
On voit les raies d’absorption associées
à l’hydrogène, au sodium, au fer,
au magnésium, etc.
Et on peut mesurer clairement le décalage
et en déduire la vitesse d’éloignement,
ici: environ 20 000 km/s.
Ça c’est pour mesurer les vitesses
d’éloignement,
en ordonnées dans le graphique de Hubble.
Et pour les distances en abscisse?
Eh bien étonnamment, c’est beaucoup
plus compliqué!
En astronomie, la mesure de la distance
des objets lointains
est une chose particulièrement délicate.
Pour y arriver, on utilise toute
une série de méthodes
qui permettent de mesurer des distances
de plus en plus lointaines.
Et ces méthodes sont liées entre elles,
puisque chacune permet d’étalonner la suivante.
L’ensemble forme ce qu’on appelle
l’échelle des distances cosmiques,
et c’était le sujet de ma vidéo précédente.
Si vous ne l’avez pas vue,
ça n’est pas très grave,
retenez simplement que la mesure
de la constante de Hubble
se fait tout en haut de l’échelle,
et que pour arriver là,
il faut avoir correctement mis en place
trois méthodes intermédiaires.
La méthode de la parallaxe,
qui permet d’estimer la distance
aux étoiles proches de façon géométrique.
Puis la méthode des Céphéides,
qui se base sur des étoiles
dont la luminosité oscille,
et qu’on arrive à détecter jusque
dans des galaxies proches.
Et enfin la méthode des supernovas,
qui exploite un certain type de supernovas
qu’on arrive à détecter
dans des galaxies beaucoup plus lointaines,
jusqu’à quelques milliards d’années-lumière.
Et donc comme je vous l’ai dit,
en combinant tout ça,
on peut estimer la valeur
de la constante de Hubble H0,
qui relie distance et vitesse d’éloignement,
et on trouve une valeur d’environ
70 km/s/Mpc.
Et ce qui est remarquable,
c’est qu’il existe une autre méthode
de mesure de cette constante, une méthode
complètement différente,
mais qui donne le même résultat.
Cette technique utilise le rayonnement
de fond diffus cosmologique.
Ce rayonnement, qu’on appelle aussi
le rayonnement fossile,
c’est une sorte de lointain écho du Big Bang,
qui prend la forme d’un rayonnement
électromagnétique
qui baigne l’ensemble de l’Univers,
et auquel on peut associer une température,
environ 2,7K.
Ce rayonnement date de l’époque où
les électrons se sont associés aux protons
pour former les premiers atomes neutres,
ce qui a permis aux photons de pouvoir
se balader librement.
Cela s’est produit quand la température
de l’Univers est passée, en gros,
sous les 3000 degrés, environ 380 000 ans
après le Big Bang.
Là aussi j’ai déjà fait toute une vidéo
qui raconte ça,
mais ce qu’il faut en retenir
c’est qu’on sait aujourd’hui
que ce rayonnement varie légèrement suivant
la direction dans laquelle on regarde.
C’est cela qui est représenté
sur les images de ce genre.
On a ici une carte du ciel, qui montre
les très légères variations
de la température du rayonnement suivant
la direction d’observation.
Ces très légères variations, on les appelle
des anisotropies,
et elles reflètent les infimes fluctuations
de densité
qui existaient dans l’Univers primordial,
au moment où le rayonnement a été émis.
On peut voir cette image comme une sorte
de photo de l’Univers
380 000 ans après le Big Bang.
Visuellement, vous remarquez peut-être
une certaine régularité
dans la granularité et la taille
des taches de couleur.
Pour quantifier cela, on peut faire
une analyse mathématique
et tracer une courbe qu’on appelle
le spectre des fluctuations.
Le plus grand pic dans le spectre est
à mettre en relation
avec la taille des taches de couleur
qu'on arrive à observer à l’œil nu.
Là vous vous dites peut-être:
c’est joli comme image,
mais quel rapport avec la constante de Hubble?
On regarde une sorte de photo de l’après
Big-Bang, il n’y a même pas de galaxies.
Et en effet, on ne va pas directement lire
la valeur de la constante de Hubble
dans la photographie du rayonnement fossile.
Pour faire le lien, on va utiliser
ce que l’on sait des mécanismes
d’expansion de l’Univers.
En cosmologie, on utilise toujours un modèle
qu’on appelle le modèle Lambda-CDM,
c’est LE modèle standard de la cosmologie,
qui a été construit à partir de la théorie
de la Relativité générale,
et de ce qu’on comprend du Big Bang.
C’est le modèle Lambda-CDM qui nous permet
de calculer
l’évolution de l’expansion de l’Univers
au cours du temps.
Il repose sur quelques ingrédients simples:
notamment CDM c’est pour Cold Dark Matter,
ça désigne la matière noire ordinaire,
et Lambda représente la fameuse
"énergie noire".
Ce modèle fonctionne extrêmement bien,
car il permet de reconstituer
toute l’histoire de l’Univers du Big Bang
jusqu’à aujourd’hui.
Il permet donc de comprendre à la fois
le rayonnement fossile
et l’expansion actuelle de l’Univers.
Et pour faire le lien entre les mesures
de rayonnement fossile
et la constante de Hubble, voici
comment on procède.
Le modèle Lambda-CDM possède un certain
nombre de paramètres en entrée,
des paramètres que l’on doit régler.
Comme la quantité de matière ordinaire,
la quantité de matière noire
et d’énergie noire,
la courbure de l’Univers, le nombre
d’espèces de neutrinos, etc.
Et on va simplement ajuster les valeurs
de ces paramètres
jusqu’à reproduire le spectre du rayonnement
fossile qu’on observe actuellement.
Puis on va dérouler le modèle
pour reconstituer
l’histoire de l’Univers et déduire la valeur
actuelle de la constante de Hubble.
Cela peut paraitre assez indirect
comme façon de faire,
mais le spectre des fluctuations
du rayonnement fossile
contient une telle quantité d’informations
que cela contraint très fortement
les valeurs possibles des paramètres
du modèle.
C’est ainsi qu’on peut déduire que l’Univers
est essentiellement plat,
qu’il contient 5% de matière ordinaire,
25% de matière noire
et environ 70% d’énergie noire.
Et l’ensemble des paramètres du modèle
Lambda-CDM qu’on détermine ainsi
nous permettent de calculer une valeur
de la constante de Hubble
d’environ 70 km/s/MPc.
Et là c’est quand même super balèze
comme résultat:
d’un côté on a une mesure directe
qui observe les galaxies,
et de l’autre on a une méthode qui utilise
des données de 380 000 ans après le Big Bang.
Et on trouve exactement la même valeur.
Succès spectaculaire de la cosmologie!
Sauf que… ça n’est pas si simple.
Quand je vous dis que les deux méthodes
donnent 70,
il faut que je sois un peu plus précis.
En physique, quand on fait une mesure,
il y a toujours une notion de barre d’erreur,
on n'est jamais infiniment précis,
et les méthodes et instruments utilisés
doivent nous permettent de quantifier
l’incertitude sur la mesure.
En 2001, la mesure directe de la constante
de Hubble par l’équipe de Wendy Freedman
a donné la valeur de 72 ± 8 km/s/Mpc.
De l’autre côté, en 2003, l’estimation issue
de l’analyse du rayonnement fossile
par le satellite WMAP a été
de 72 ± 5 km/s/Mpc.
Il faut bien comprendre ce que veulent dire
ces barres d’erreur,
72 ± 5, ça ne veut pas dire que c’est
à coup sûr entre 67 et 77.
Il faut faire un raisonnement avec
des probabilités.
Ici ± 5, fonctionne comme un écart-type,
on peut tracer une courbe en cloche
qui montre la probabilité estimée
des différentes valeurs d’après
les mesures réalisées.
La moyenne c’est 72, et l’écart type est de 5.
Et vous voyez que ça n’interdit pas
des valeurs au-dessus de 77
ou en dessous de 67, elles sont justes
moins probables.
On peut raisonner sous forme d’intervalle
de confiance.
Avec un écart-type de 5, on estime
qu’il y a 68% de chances
que la vraie valeur soit dans
un intervalle de ± 5,
et 95% de chance qu’elle soit dans
un intervalle de ± 10, deux fois l’écart-type.
Ça, en rouge, c’est la courbe de probabilité
pour la mesure par le rayonnement fossile,
et si je superpose celle par mesure directe,
72 ± 8,
vous voyez que les deux courbes sont
très largement compatibles.
Mais les deux valeurs que je vous ai données
datent du début des années 2000.
Entre temps les mesures se sont améliorées,
de nouveaux satellites ont été lancés
et les estimations sont devenues
de plus en plus précises,
avec des barres d’erreurs de plus
en plus faible, en voici l’évolution.
L’axe horizontal, ici, c’est le temps.
En bleu vous avez les mesures obtenues
par méthode directe,
et en rouge par la mesure
du rayonnement fossile.
On part des années 2000 avec les valeurs
que je vous ai annoncées.
On voit qu’au cours du temps les estimations
sont devenues de plus en plus précises.
Pour le rayonnement fossile, il y a eu
notamment de gros progrès
réalisés grâce au satellite Planck
lancé en 2009.
La dernière estimation de Planck
a été publiée en 2018, et c’était 67,4 ± 0,5.
Et la dernière estimation par mesure directe,
issue de la collaboration SH0ES est tombée
il y a quelques semaines, en décembre 2021
à 73,04 ± 1,04.
Et là je pense que vous commencez
à voir ce problème
qu’on appelle la tension de Hubble.
Si on revient à notre estimation sous forme
de courbe de probabilité,
si on prend les deux dernières mesures,
voici à quoi ça ressemble maintenant.
Vous voyez que les deux estimations
deviennent largement incompatibles.
La différence entre les deux est d’environ
5 fois l’écart-type,
on dit qu’il y a une tension de 5 sigmas
entre les deux estimations.
Cinq sigmas, ça veut dire que
si tout était correct,
il n’y aurait qu’une chance sur un million
que l’on ait réalisé de telles mesures.
Intuitivement vous vous dite peut-être que
si les deux méthodes sont en désaccord,
c’est certainement qu’elles sont fausses
toutes les deux,
et que la vérité c’est de faire la moyenne
et de taper au milieu.
Genre la bonne valeur de la constante
de Hubble ça doit être pile 70.
Mais en fait non, ça ne résout rien
de dire ça.
Si la vraie valeur c’était réellement 70,
ça veut dire qu’on aurait remplacé
une tension monstrueuse
par deux tensions énormes.
Parce qu’aucune des deux méthodes n’est
aujourd’hui d’accord avec cette valeur de 70.
Avec ce genre de situation, on ne peut pas
se contenter de dire:
on fait la moyenne des deux.
Il faut qu’on comprenne d’où vient la tension.
Et c’est pour ça que le petit monde
de la cosmologie
semble être en crise depuis quelques années.
Alors comment débloquer la situation?
Intuitivement il y a deux possibilités.
Premièrement la mesure directe peut
être fausse
à cause d’une ou plusieurs sources d’erreurs
qu’on n'aurait pas prises en compte,
auxquelles on n'aurait pas pensé,
ou qu’on aurait mal quantifiées.
Ou bien inversement, peut-être que c’est
la mesure du rayonnement fossile
qui contient des sources d’erreurs
qui faussent l’estimation de la constante
de la Hubble.
Un problème avec le satellite Planck,
dans la récolte ou le traitement des données.
Mais en plus de ces deux hypothèses,
il y a aussi une troisième option.
Vous vous rappelez que pour faire
l’estimation à partir du rayonnement fossile,
on utilise une route indirecte qui passe
par l’utilisation du modèle Lambda-CDM.
On ajuste les paramètres du modèle
jusqu’à ce qu’il reproduise
le rayonnement fossile.
Et une fois qu’on a ça,
on a la constante de Hubble.
Peut-être que les mesures du rayonnement
fossile sont très bonnes,
mais que c’est le modèle qui est faux,
peut-être que le modèle Lambda-CDM
est trop simpliste,
et que la cosmologie et l’histoire
de l’Univers seraient
finalement un peu plus compliquées que ça?
Alors examinons ensemble les trois hypothèses.
Pour la mesure directe, on a besoin
de connaitre la vitesse d’éloignement
et la distance d’un grand nombre de galaxies.
Pour la vitesse d’éloignement, la méthode
est assez simple et fiable,
mais avec une subtilité: la vitesse
apparente d’une galaxie par rapport à nous
est en réalité la somme de deux contributions.
Une qui est due à l’expansion de l’Univers,
celle qui nous intéresse,
et une qui est simplement sa vitesse propre
par rapport à nous.
Cette vitesse propre, on sait qu’elle va être
au maximum de quelques centaines de km/s.
Mais pour que notre mesure ne soit pas
trop affectée par cela,
il va falloir aller chercher des galaxies
vraiment lointaines,
dont les vitesses d’éloignement surpassent
largement la vitesse propre.
On ne peut pas se contenter d’estimer
la constante de Hubble
sur les galaxies voisines, on risquerait
d’être trop perturbé par leur vitesse propre.
Et c’est là qu’intervient le problème,
si on va chercher des galaxies de plus
en plus lointaines,
il faut de très bonnes estimations
de leurs distances, et ça c’est compliqué.
Je vous ai dit qu’on utilisait toute
une série de méthodes
qui permettaient d’aller
de plus en plus loin,
mais qui dépendaient les unes des autres,
on parle de l’échelle
des distances cosmiques,
et chaque méthode sert à étalonner
la suivante.
C'est tout l’objet de ma vidéo précédente.
Et donc si on commet une légère erreur
sur un des premiers barreaux de l’échelle,
eh bien cela va fausser
tout ce qui vient après.
Il y a notamment deux passages critiques.
Pour passer de la méthode de la parallaxe
à celle des Céphéides,
il faut étalonner ce qu’on appelle
la loi de Leavitt.
C’est une relation découverte par l’astronome
Henrietta Leavitt,
et qui relie la luminosité et la pulsation
de ces étoiles variables Céphéides.
Le deuxième passage critique,
c’est d’exploiter les Céphéides
pour estimer les distances des supernovas
qu’on va considérer dans le diagramme
de Hubble.
Et ça, ça n’est pas simple, car des supernovas,
il ne s’en présente pas tous les jours.
Tous ces travaux de vérification ont
notamment été consolidés dans le cadre
d’une collaboration appelée SH0ES,
et dirigée par l’américain Adam Riess.
Adam Riess qui n’est pas un nouveau venu,
puisqu’il faisait déjà partie
des lauréats du prix de Nobel
de Physique 2011
pour sa découverte de l’expansion accélérée
de l’Univers grâce aux supernovas.
Pour blinder au maximum le résultat
de la mesure directe,
l’équipe de la collaboration SH0Es
a utilisé de nombreuses méthodes:
des mesures améliorées de parallaxe
des Céphéides,
notamment grâce au satellite Gaïa,
dont je vous avais parlé
dans la vidéo précédente,
mais aussi des mesures ponctuelles
par des méthodes autre que la parallaxe.
Ils ont également essayé d’ajouter
d’autres étoiles que les Céphéides
en guise de deuxième barreau.
Et enfin ils ont analysé de nouvelles
supernovas
permettant de faire passer de 19 à 40
le nombre servant à la calibration du lien
entre Céphéides et Supernovas.
Et c’est grâce à toutes ces précautions
et améliorations
qu’ils ont publié en décembre 2021
leur nouvelle estimation
de la constante de Hubble
à 73,04 ± 1,04.
Évidemment, ça n’empêche pas de se dire
qu’il pourrait y avoir un problème de fond
dans toute cette méthode,
et l’idéal, ce serait de disposer
d’une autre mesure directe,
mais complètement indépendante de
cette échelle des distances cosmiques.
Et il se trouve qu’il y a deux options:
La première c’est d’utiliser
un phénomène très rare,
les effets de lentilles gravitationnelles
sur les quasars.
Ce sont des situations où se forment
de multiples images d’un même objet lointain,
du fait de la déviation des rayons lumineux
par la courbure locale de l’espace.
C’est ce qu’a entrepris la collaboration
HoLiCOW,
qui grâce à l’utilisation de 6 quasars
de ce type a fourni
une estimation de la constante de Hubble
à 73,3 ± 1,8
Donc plutôt le même ordre de grandeur
qu’avec l’échelle des distances.
Une autre option complètement différente
de mesure directe,
c’est d’utiliser les ondes gravitationnelles,
que l’on arrive maintenant à détecter grâce
aux interféromètres LIGO et VIRGO.
avec la technique de ce qu'on appelle
les "sirènes standards".
On sait que les ondes que l’on détecte
avec ces instruments correspondent
aux derniers instants de la fusion
d’objets massifs
comme des étoiles à neutrons
ou des trous noirs.
Et la façon dont le signal évolue
nous renseigne précisément
sur ce qu’il s’est passé,
et nous permet d’en déduire l’énergie
émise lors de l’événement.
Et si on arrive à détecter ces événements
de fusion conjointement
dans les ondes gravitationnelles,
et dans le spectre électromagnétique,
c’est-à-dire avec un télescope normal,
on peut alors en déduire
la distance et la vitesse, et estimer
la constante de Hubble.
Le souci c’est qu’à l’heure où je fais cette
vidéo, une double observation de ce genre,
une sirène standard où on a à la fois
ondes gravitationnelles
et ondes électromagnétiques,
ça ne s’est produit qu’une seule fois,
avec l’événement appelé GW170817.
Et celui-ci a permis d’estimer la valeur
de la constante de Hubble à 70… ±10.
Ça ne nous aide pas beaucoup à résoudre
la tension,
mais avec plus d’événements, ça pourrait
changer la donne à l’avenir.
Quoiqu’il en soit, la détermination
par les méthodes directes semble
bien confirmer une valeur située autour
de 72-73.
Voyons maintenant s’il pourrait y avoir
un problème avec le rayonnement fossile.
[jingle]
Pour ce qui est des mesures à partir
du rayonnement fossile,
les estimations les plus récentes
nous viennent du satellite Planck.
Ce dernier a permis la mesure
de l’anisotropie du rayonnement fossile
avec une précision spectaculaire,
permettant d’obtenir cette courbe
qui est le spectre des anisotropies
de température.
En rouge vous voyez les données
expérimentales,
et en bleu l’ajustement obtenu
à partir du modèle Lambda-CDM,
et qui permet de déterminer précisément
les valeurs des paramètres
cosmologiques du modèle.
Et tout cela conduit donc à 67,4 ± 0,5
pour la constante de Hubble.
Alors pourrait-il y a voir une erreur
là-dedans?
Il faut bien voir une chose, c’est que
pour passer des mesures brutes du satellite
à cette belle courbe, il faut un énorme
travail de traitement des données.
Et on pourrait imaginer des erreurs
dans tout ce processus.
Ça n’est pas absurde comme suggestion,
il y avait eu un précédent en 2014,
avec l’expérience qui s’appelait BICEP2.
L’équipe avait annoncé à grands coups
de communication
la découverte d’ondes gravitationnelles
dans le rayonnement fossile,
et la preuve de l’inflation primordiale…
Champagne!
Ils se voyaient déjà avec le Nobel…
avant de découvrir
qu’il y avait un petit souci dans
leur procédure de traitement des données.
Et ce sont d’ailleurs les mesures de Planck
qui ont permis de mettre un point final
à l’affaire,
et de montrer que la collaboration BICEP2
n’avait pas détecté
ce qui avait été initialement annoncé.
Donc de façon similaire, est-ce qu'on peut
vraiment être confiants
sur la valeur de la constante de Hubble
donnée par Planck?
Une manière de se rassurer, c’est déjà
de savoir que les chercheurs
utilisent deux procédures de traitement
différentes, Plik et CamSpec,
et qu’elles fournissent des résultats
extrêmement similaires.
Ça éloigne la probabilité d’un bug idiot.
Et puis surtout comme pour le cas
de la mesure directe,
on dispose d’une autre méthode
pour corroborer ce résultat.
Ce qu’on appelle l’oscillation acoustique
des baryons.
Je vous l’ai dit, ces petites fluctuations
dans le rayonnement fossile
traduisent de légères fluctuations
de densité
qui existaient 380 000 ans après le Big Bang.
Ces fluctuations étaient le résultat
d’ondes de pression
qui se propageaient dans le plasma primordial.
Et c’est pour ça qu’on leur donne le nom
d’oscillations acoustiques.
Les pics qu’on observe sur le spectre
des fluctuations du rayonnement fossile,
on peut les voir comme
les différentes harmoniques
de ces ondes acoustiques primordiales.
Mais avec l’expansion de l’Univers
ces fluctuations de densité
se sont amplifiées,
et ce sont elles qui sont à l’origine
de l’existence
et de la répartition des galaxies
qu’on observe aujourd’hui.
Les fluctuations de densité qu'on voit
dans le rayonnement fossile
ont servi de graines de départ pour
la distribution des galaxies dans l’Univers.
Or on sait mesurer une légère inhomogénéité
de cette répartition.
C’est ce qu’a réalisé par exemple
la collaboration SDSS,
qui a mesuré la densité des galaxies
dans plusieurs directions
et ce jusqu’à des distances d’une dizaine
de milliards d’années-lumière.
Voici le genre d’image qu’ils ont
reconstituées.
Et on devine que la répartition des galaxies
n’y est pas totalement homogène.
C’est difficile à caractériser à l’œil nu,
mais il y a dans ces données
une granularité, qui se trouve être
la descendance
de la granularité qu’on observait
dans le rayonnement fossile.
Une analyse mathématique permet de quantifier
l’échelle de cette granularité.
Elle est d’environ 150Mpc.
Cela veut dire qu’en moyenne quand on a
une zone riche en galaxies quelque part,
on aura d’autres zones riches à environ
150 Mpc de distance.
C’est ce qu’on appelle l’oscillation
acoustique des baryons, BAO pour les intimes.
Et ces mesures permettent elles aussi
d’estimer
la constante de Hubble à 67,9 ± 1,1.
Sensiblement dans la même zone que
les mesures du rayonnement fossile.
En résumé, on a deux types de mesures.
Les mesures directes, par l’échelle
des distances cosmiques
ou par des méthodes alternatives comme
les effets de lentilles sur les quasars.
On parle de mesure tardives: "Late Universe",
puisque ces mesures se basent sur
l’expansion de l’Univers
telle qu’on l’observe aujourd’hui.
Et puis on a le rayonnement fossile
et les oscillations acoustiques des baryons,
on parle de mesures primitives:
"Early Universe",
puisqu’elles nous renseignent sur
des phénomènes ayant eu lieu
seulement quelques centaines de milliers
d’années après le Big Bang.
Et quelles que soient les méthodes
qu’on regarde,
et avec toutes les vérifications
possibles à ce stade,
il semble toujours y avoir une tension
entre les mesures "Late"
et les mesures "Early".
Mais, je l’ai dit, si les mesures
sont correctes,
il peut y avoir une troisième option
pour expliquer la tension.
L’origine de tout cela, cela pourrait bien
être en définitive
notre modèle du Big Bang,
le modèle Lambda-CDM.
On l’a dit, le modèle Lambda-CDM est
un ingrédient essentiel
de l’estimation de la constante de Hubble
à partir du rayonnement fossile.
On ajuste les paramètres du modèle
pour coller au spectre des fluctuations,
et on en déduit la constante de Hubble.
Mais si ce modèle était légèrement faux?
Après tout on sait que ce modèle n’est pas
vraiment fondamental.
C’est ce que les physiciens appellent
un modèle effectif:
un modèle où on introduit des ingrédients
pour modéliser notre ignorance,
mais sans qu’on sache forcément
les expliquer.
Par exemple dans le modèle Lambda-CDM,
il y a au moins 3 de ces ingrédients:
l’inflation, la matière noire
et l’énergie noire.
On les prend en compte via des paramètres,
et ça fonctionne magnifiquement bien.
Mais on n’a pas de compréhension profonde
des phénomènes qui en seraient à l’origine.
Et si, avec ce modèle effectif,
on ratait quelque chose?
S’il y avait ce que les physiciens appellent
de la « nouvelle physique »?
Des phénomènes encore inconnus,
qu’il faudrait prendre en compte,
et qui modifieraient légèrement
le modèle Lambda CDM?
Pour le savoir, on pourrait essayer
de changer légèrement le modèle
d’une façon qui fasse remonter l’estimation
"Early Universe" de la constante de Hubble.
Ça parait facile, on n’a qu’à saupoudrer
un ou deux ingrédients en plus
dans les équations.
Alors non, ça n’est pas si simple que ça,
car on dispose de tellement de mesures
astrophysiques solides,
qu’il n’est pas évident de toucher juste
à un bout du modèle sans tout casser.
Notamment les mesures d’oscillations
acoustiques des baryons
contraignent énormément les modifications
possibles.
Malgré tout la créativité des théoriciens
est sans limite
et une revue récente a listé plus d’une
centaine de nouvelles théories proposées
dans le but de réduire la tension de Hubble,
en voici quelques extraits:
Anharmonic oscillation…
[lecture accélérée de la liste… en anglais]
Phantom dark energy…!
[Cannibal dark matter
Unparticals!!! ]
[Uber gravity… ]
[Super Lambda CDM, Double Lambda CDM!!
ETC. ETC.]
Bon, pas la peine de m'envoyer vos théories
en commentaire,
c'est bon, je crois qu'on a ce qu'il faut!
Les approches les plus prometteuses
semblent essayer de toucher
surtout aux périodes primordiales
du Big Bang,
à l’époque du rayonnement fossile et avant.
Par exemple en imaginant une énergie noire
variant avec le temps,
ou bien des interactions inconnues
aujourd'hui
qui se seraient manifestées uniquement
dans ces conditions extrêmes,
mais qu’on ne détecterait plus aujourd’hui:
de nouvelles particules, de nouveaux champs,
de nouvelles forces.
Mais il semble que malgré tous les efforts
des théoriciens,
aucune solution franchement convaincante
n’existe aujourd’hui.
Beaucoup de modifications du modèle
Lambda-CDM
conduisent à une réduction de la tension,
mais surtout parce qu’elles augmentent
les barres d’erreurs,
plus qu’elles ne réduisent l’écart
entre les deux façon de mesurer.
Malgré tout, il faut persévérer, aussi bien
sur le plan théorique qu’expérimental.
Qui sait? Peut-être que cette légère
tension permettra de déboucher
sur une révolution conceptuelle.
Après tout c’était ce qui s’était passé
avec l’orbite de Mercure,
qui a finalement été expliquée
par la Relativité générale,
révolutionnant au passage notre conception
de la gravité.
Certes, tout cela ressemble à une crise
de la cosmologie.
Mais c’est peut-être justement
une opportunité formidable
de réaliser de grands progrès dans
notre compréhension des lois de l’Univers.
Merci d’avoir suivi la vidéo jusqu’au bout.
Si vous voulez en savoir plus,
je vous recommande le billet de blog,
le lien est en description.
Un grand merci à Louise Breuval, qui a eu
la gentillesse de répondre à mes questions.
C’est une astrophysicienne française qui
a fait sa thèse à l’Observatoire de Paris,
et qui travaille maintenant avec Adam Riess
sur l’amélioration de la détermination
de la constante de Hubble.
C’est un peu la classe!
Abonnez vous, si ça n’est pas déjà fait,
mettez la cloche, partagez la vidéo
et nous on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle vidéo.
À bientôt.
– Sous-titrage: Le Crayon d'oreille -